Yesterday was Veterans Day, a somber day on
which we remember those who gave time from
their lives to serve in the military.
And I have said this before.
I think what you want about the missions our
military is sent on, that's a political issue.
And I often disagree with the missions our
military is sent on, but I never ignore or
miss that we don't have a draft in this country.
And I didn't have to do any military stuff
because enough people volunteered to do it.
Now, it's a perfectly fair criticism to say,
well, the problem is the people volunteering
to do it are not diverse enough in terms of
political background and whatever.
You know, when it's volunteer only, you get
a certain type of people in the military.
That's a conversation we can have.
We can say there are certain folks not well
enough represented among the military.
The military is preying on people of color.
Fine, fine.
But I remain thrilled that I didn't have to
do anything in the military because enough
people are volunteering.
So it's a somber day, you know, etc..
Joe Biden tweeted a message of sober respect,
saying, quote, Today, we honor the service
of those who have worn the uniform of the
armed forces of the United States to our proud
veterans.
I will be a commander in chief who respects
your sacrifice, understands your service,
and will never betray the values you fought
so bravely to defend.
That's Biden.
Donald Trump, meanwhile, much like on Veterans
Day in years past, made it all about himself.
And yesterday it was conspiracy theories about
how he really won the election and how he
really won the state of Pennsylvania.
Trump tweeting, quote, A guy named Al Schmidt,
a Philadelphia commissioner and so-called
Republican RINO is being used big time by
the fake news media to explain how honest
things were with respect to the election in
Philadelphia.
He refuses to look at the mountain of corruption
and dishonesty.
We win.
Now, aside from the, again, completely disrespectful
nature of Donald Trump doing this on Veterans
Day, as a reminder, the closer we get to one
hundred percent of the Pennsylvania vote being
counted, the bigger Joe Biden's lead is actually
getting.
It recently surpassed forty nine thousand
votes onward and beyond to fifty thousand
votes inching closer to Biden, winning Pennsylvania
by a full percentage point, putting it out
of recount territory.
But it doesn't matter.
Trump doesn't care.
Veterans Day.
It's about him.
It's all about him.
Trump also tweeting just before the start
of Veterans Day video from Fox News's Laura
Ingraham Show promoting once again voter fraud,
conspiracy theories.
And this really shouldn't surprise us because
Donald Trump has never cared about veterans
as people remember that during his presidency,
which will soon be over, Donald Trump cared
about using the VA as an example to claim
successes.
Many times Donald Trump claimed we did veterans
choice.
In reality, that was Barack Obama's program
from 2014.
Trump cared about using soldiers as props.
Trump even said during the coronavirus pandemic
that he continued to meet with military families,
Gold Star families during the pandemic.
What a great guy.
And he even suggested that it might have been
because he continued to meet with Gold Star
Families, that he caught Coronavirus maybe
from one of them.
He actually said that, if you can believe
it.
So what we're ultimately getting to hear is,
number one, this is the last Veterans Day
on which Donald Trump will do this as president
unless he runs in twenty four and wins.
But we're not going to really deal with that
for the time being.
Few.
For veterans days, I do imagine Trump will
continue to tweet, I did more for veterans
when I was president than anyone else or something
like that.
He'll still make it about himself in the future.
But the other thing which we're going to be
talking about today and on tomorrow's program
is that this entire voter fraud thing that
Donald Trump has been pushing, it's working
in a few different ways.
He has convinced 86 percent of Republicans.
We're going to look at the polling tomorrow.
86 percent of Republicans now believe Joe
Biden is not the legitimate winner of the
2020 election.
That's a very serious mind virus for which
we seem to have no vaccine, there's no inoculation.
I guess critical thinking and education are
are the inoculation.
But that is there's a significant dearth of
that in the United States.
And also privately, the latest news is that
Donald Trump knows he doesn't actually have
a path to victory through these lawsuits and
claims, but that he's doing it as theater.
And, of course, the sick reality of that is
there are people who can't afford it who are
donating to Donald Trump because they believe
maybe their donations will help overturn the
results.
It's sick and will deal with all of that in
the next 24 hours.
Let me know your thoughts about the Veterans
Day fiasco once again for Donald Trump via
Twitter, where you can find me at Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.